all right a new video something else
someone requested that we kingscrusher
any we do a quick bullet match and so
here we go I accidentally played the
French and now I'm in a in a somewhat
bad position in this a lackin or
whatever is pronounced should i attack
with with h for white just better with
pressure on the FR i hope i somehow can
untangle myself we gave me five this was
nice trying to consolidate here
rg3 should have taken g3 I think I night
at five is got a 95 and this one as well
g7 was threatening so this night doesn't
have much squares by the way we do a
match first to UM win five games so yeah
this was first one trying to play dry
position where you can move quickly I
still don't feel yet awake it's early in
the morning here yeah this is very h7
actually singing this is a very nice
position should be winning we have one
coming up yeah it is supposed to an
exchange sloth
actually place plus the main line oops
very lucky this was very close to a
mouse disaster okay yeah this should be
should be okay for me I think this is
somewhat somewhere uncomfortable here
this night should win material actually
exchanged our peace now this check mail
yeah 330 litres nice start yeah
somewhere we got into a kind of yeah if
you're a kettle Greenfeld I want to open
it up here I saw this but at this point
is saying what I thought I could get
some play yeah not the best idea
obviously mmm the artist will look at
this ok it's only to try to fight so
very bad of course it's not really
threatening he is threatening the
discoveries
yeah don't want to note maybe I can get
some tricks on the king black pieces are
somewhat somewhat turn badly coordinated
here rooks on the edge file would be
made and look H forwarded in good I'm
also close to overstepping the time okay
yeah
yeah okay let's try to activate this
this Bishop f6 okay let's let's try this
looks interesting okay just protected
not quite sure this Bishop is maybe just
just badly place them matric let that
exchanged it is of course totally
winning her white but could easily go on
slow and turn this low
yeah yeah some quiet London London
system I'm still only to really speed up
here in general otherwise it simply
won't help me to have good positions you
know maybeee 45 by okay that but this
would also activate this bishop I have
another idea trying to get the night
here see what you would be able to play
a for which it somehow doesn't do
this was bad okay could have taken on d3
get sassy fall you know I'm okay again
maybe even better now yeah long time
yeah some are we got into a French again
and of course f3 was a nice trick to
wrong-foot me and somehow okay d to to
break the spin
can get meat haha our bullet in the
morning oh fun okay yeah Queens gambit
declined with Bishop f4 always like this
variation or seem very very comfortable
for white try to get some play on c6
black is not enough terrible here needs
to try to get an itune to see for which
she tries ok but I have this tactic c8
is hanging
yeah c6 also difficult to defend what
now do I have some great move here
somewhere this an idea doesn't do much
actually this is where this is fine now
c6 hanging and he ate hanging don't
think you can cover both know I'm low on
time and overlook this stupid trick it's
unbelievable how was the rook up hahaha
ok no man this match should have been
over
yeah this is very closed of course it
should be should be okay for me I can
can open it out of this way yeah please
this time hopefully i win and not get
mated with look up or something yep 54
yeah and that's not the greatest in
terms of quality what I hope you got
entertained by me missing amazing one
and stuff like that okay well thanks for
watching and see you soon with new
videos